Yes. It's much less. Get your number right here. One would have hoped that.
Folks settling in this community would have been enormously industrious. To build.
Allow impact lyda man sustainable lifestyle. Planning perma culture across the hillsides.
Vegetable gardens in the rich volcanic soil. Learning. Skills to support themselves a canonically.
I've not done any scientific analysis of this
but it seems to me a third of the people would make very little if any effort in those directions at all.
Another third makes another third quite industrious. That's why one would have hoped because there's a crying need.
Across the planet. For a low impact lyda man sustainable lifestyle. To reign in the arena successes and weist of.
Rampant consumerism in the materialistic west. But also to show a viable y. Of fulfilling life to the impoverished.
World. The sort of. Alternatives a saudi which exists in pockets in it around the region.
Does bear these characteristics it does show a far future direction for planetary civilization. But that.
Manifestation.
It has been severely damaged by the one third who contribute nothing in one thirty you contribute only a little.
As much. Well as a lawyer. I was i able to practice without fear of employment. And was unable to gain employment.
Locally. Because of resentment from a very conservative profession.
So i had to go out of the gulf coast to get a job and. Polish up my skills again.
I have done that and couldn't move back now.
Set up my own practice that lacks capital to really do so
and will send the children to going to school on the gulf coast now. So lot of good things down here.
Which are very attractive. Didn't close the mountains growing one's own food. The various aspects of.
Alternative culture which are so positive like home birthing. The bush music scene. Alternative power.
Alternative healing. It's a fun.
It's a fun culture to live in and and develop a lot hocking back to what our saying earlier.
I think that the welfare and the actions of. Black market.
Marijuana growing and dealing with has had a spin off with a considerable portion of. Of heroin users and.
What pad a spin it fetter mean type uses. Of the downside of that. Positive culture.
Of course those downsides exist through. At society there. I haven't just limited to this one. That.
The shame of it is the enormous. National and planetary need for this sort of.
Now impact light amount lost all of the evidence in a fairly positive. Why.
And one would have hoped after twenty years. A lot more would have been achieved and has been.
I found it at the time rather. Airy fairy and. He hated mystic.
But i hoped that people would be able to implement that idealism into.
Nuts and bolts reality of homes and what should and local industries and craft. The first five or ten years.
Folk would say oh we're shell shocked from being in the world at so we need to turn inwards and observe night sure
and get some sort of centering on what we're going to do and why. And i kept saying that for another five years.
I think after twenty years. With really got to bridge the gap between the intellectual ideals.
And the nuts and bolts physical reality. You know strider which is going down the should be economically.
That's not good enough to keep putting one's hand out to the public purse. No doubt.
There's a horrific rich poor gap in australia. Which justifies the. Economically. Underprivileged sections.
Receiving some. Well fair. No doubt. The receipt of that welfare.
Relieves revolutionary type pressure on that ten percent which controls not a descent of the wealth.
Welfare is a good
and just thing in the present economic arrangement that once criticism must go to the present political economic
arrangement. It's preserving. This rich poor that. It's preserving a.
Enormous weist of energy in government and bureaucracy. It's my thesis that by adopting a body centralized system.
With political power maximized in local areas and. Economic independence.
Maximized as much as possible in local areas so as to obviate the need for transportation. So a lot of this.
Wastage of money on. Central government and. The concentration of wealth in a few hands can be avoided.
This is sink a simple one simple answer to a stranger's economic political imbalance.
And that is to replace all taxation. With site revenue. So it revenue should be the sole source of public finance.
Site revenue is a collection of the yeah new all right all value of sites privately occupied with various sorts be on
the air and water oil. Whether those sites be used for residence. Commercial industrial. Public or any other use.
Sites which should be free of paying site revenue. Would be to.
Then which is truly open to the public at any time such as roads. National parks beaches. Land which is held by.
Government bodies such as. Ministries or local government including church land. All of that.
Should pay the annual rental value of the site occupied. To the community.
This would force stay on the price of land such that. Land would eventually transfer.
Only for the value of improvements upon it. This would.
Be severe disincentive to people earning more land than they have to.
Would make a lot of land available for the present unemployed.
Folk to settle and pineal survive a lot of stalls like their forefathers did. Because workers would have this choice.
Of independence. On their own. Smallholding. So there'd be. Competition for labor and.
Rewards for lybia would naturally be high without the necessity for union action.
No longer would there be the massive imposts upon. Effort and creativity. Which income tax payer of tax stamp duties..
Financial institution taxes. And horror of horrors a proposed g.s.t. Embroil. In the industrious person in suffering.
That's a simple solution. Sought revenue. That's right. And i did. This been great advances on various cultural fronts.
Such as community based preschool ing and primary schooling. Birthing. Bush music. Alternative power.
There are good examples of perma culture. And so subsistence. I'd say it's gone. A decent. Why down the track in.
Evidencing what's possible. Although to me personally the. Progress has been. Saddening only in adequate.
Where we shouldn't could have been at this time. Reality and. Yes it could it could. It could be.
The hard knocks is this really. It is difficult to struggle with inadequate capital to build and plant.
It's so easy to getting caught up in the effort of day to day living. Family tensions.
The sheer problems of living hard in an area like this with without. Often without electricity and with heavy rainfall.
Many people can't afford. The basic price of a share in land. Which is usually gone.
Beyond the original two hundred dollars which title was timed cuttable is now about twelve or fifteen hundred.
With difficult conditions of approval to be met before. Any shares granted.
Really they could and should have been dozens or. Or scores of large scale community settlements like tangible.
That the high price of land has made that. Difficult. There was one effort. Several years ago.
Tire mcadory on the cayuga road where the south wales. Department of. Think it was housing. Assisted in setting up or.
Allow impact. Type. Community with with subsidised share prices which could be paid back.
Over a period even by someone receiving welfare. And fortunately that whole exercise. Was severely damaged by.
One element of settlers who wanted to grow marijuana.
Which was obviously contrary to the mandate of franchise the state government had entrusted to those steering the
community. And then it was a change of government and the south wales liberals quickly ended the adventure that.
To answer your question. There's a lot of physical difficulties in fulfilling the ideals.
That in a world which is suffering such threats to its continued existence. From pollution. Poverty unemployment.
Economic illness. It's incumbent upon. Every one of us to keep those ideals in mind. Do our best to achieve it.
And not cut down. As being. Abnormally tall poppies. Other individuals who. Exhort folk to i aim at those ideals.
And even.
Exhort them to cease wasting the potentials we have such crying planetary and national need to achieve those ideals.
Well i think my favorite memory happens every dawn and dusk. When stillness. Descends on the valley and.
The goods and the incredible variety and richness call the clear sounds back and forth. Like something. Yes definitely.
At the bend alex. Attracted me here to settle.
You may be aware that bet me out warnings the highest mountain in the strider that receives the first sunlight of adorn
touching this continent. And it's a plug of an ancient park. The rim of that ultra ancient volcanoes the nightcap.
Range here in the south where tuttle billie's the tweed range in the west
and the macpherson range on the queensland border. So if you look at it.
On a broad scale contour map you'll see a veritable circle of mountains.
Centered on mount warning so for twenty years i saw this is actually a man dialect across which and you are.
Civilization could be built and. Demonstrating a valuable.
Way of life for the rest of the nation and the guard in that case. There is an infinite consciousness.
Some might call it god i think jesus christ was a true individual who to the highest extent embodied that consciousness
is not something one can intellectualize very well. That living close to nature. They're going one's own food.
Yeah i've been happy. And felt at peace with the universe and. That's all the spiritual insight i require. Thank you.
Ok take six hundred ninety nine and. They're kind of thinking about what is it. He says. Health care your life and.
Someone tell me it's. I mean a nation for a sewer. Stright you or. I can name in soft technology engineers texas.
Kallie mclaughlin. And i'm very busy working for run by power at the moment.
But i still live in this community as i've done for nineteen years now. But if you and.
I first came to nimbin for the queerest festival. When i came up with a wonderful contingent of ten.
Hippies from mina sydney. And we brought with us a prefabricated dime. And put it up on the paddock.
The side of newman. And we had an unbelievably amazing two weeks.
It was sort of like a dry run for what could be possible in the wife. Soft technology. And it worked nicely.
What a wonderful time. And the. The bamboo and plastic done which is quite big.
We eventually thatched tightly and with setting on it made it perfectly respectable building.
We had a fall place in the middle and. Mets all around it. And it was a bit like a tape.
Buckminster fuller tape it was a concept that you know. Music was a bit of that broke revolve all things starting and.
Also the celtic revival. And there's a great spirit. Of ancient. Momentum. That was happening at that stage and.
We had a in anderson from the doors playing bach. Minuets interspersed with brock music it was. I guess you'd call it.
Broken celtic infusion of the rock music which is a driving anti society force at that stage.
And being a musician of some sort also extremely interested. And attracted by this expression of culture.
The idea was to somehow. Have the best of city culture. While the best of country. Environment.
And if you could some help and expect to get that then you'd be really in paradise.
And on top of that goes the odd deal of political autonomy. The been a lot of political repression at this stage.
And very much this utopian movement of the sixty's and seventy's was a response to political repression.
A lot of very strong. Notions. In the white legislature at that stage was set up and.
Most of us had been on the wrong side of the war either. Everything from drinking in public smoke marijuana.
Right through to conscription. So we had very little time three. Establishment. Odd loral policed. As you can.
Also totally respectable mathematics teacher. Tried to become a physicist. And i wasn't quite in the top notch.
Group of students enough to to achieve that.
I ended up becoming a teacher is the anyway financing myself through university.
I became a teacher but not a very good one. Eventually decided that.
Educating people for destructive and nonexistent jobs. Was you know. Limited potential. I thought that.
Create a changing things much more fundamentally than simply in educating people in school to tolerate the system was
more practical. Not long. And six months i came here to live. Since the festival i'd start.
Actually before the festival i decided i was going to live in the north in rivers coming in any questions which one.
I've been up in a lens which is right close to my home. Looking to settle in there.
And didn't feel very welcome at any of the.
Communes which were being set up up and down the coast at that time in the querist movement.
Had much more political strength and integrity to it.
Any of the previous which were really just like extended family groups. And for that reason i joined this commune.
It was beak. Had a certain inertia to it. That meant that.
Personality issues didn't end up dominating the politics and the audiology and. In that why. The political process.
And the corporate structure of this place were very superior to anything else which it happened.
They get much more rights to the individual. Is that you. Know. Because it was never explicitly applied.
I think i can think of many cases where this community only stayed together because of its political structure.
And there are lots of parallels with other.
Communes at the same time which didn't have the political structure which fell apart.
And when the necessary conflicts of interest turned up. There was the form. And the communication.
In this coming in to to sort out things. So when we. We faced. All of the.
The big issues that any intentional community faces. Which is work obligations. Impact on.
Sharing resources and ironically that gets translated into reality is. Guns. Dogs and fences.
That's the bottom line of a conflict. Often.
That's just a symptom of the underlying conflict but that's what always bubbles out.
And our community did a better job of managing those set. Subjects than many of the others with less structure.
You took. Yes. Yes. And then. Politics and politics were not.
Issues that the corporate structure of the commune dealt with. Regional issues. Is that.
I think possibly for that reason i got much more nasty. And more involved with personal power politics.
Rather than with. Overall principles and god lance. And.
The seems to me is where the individual comes up against the community i think when issues of water
and diaper involved and. Death of course was a financial ticket.
It was a very quick and easy way of getting money which was the thing which is my short in supply here. And.
The dole was equally powerful. But that didn't really in pins nearly so much on the community structure.
Was water and both were strong incentives for people to work in an actively. Anti social matter. For their own games.
And that's what happened. So i think so yes. With water. It was come.
Compounded by the fact that most people don't understand how water works. It's intellectually difficult.
Particularly for people with di paddled brians. And i think most of the.
What is seen as like an unbelievable self interest. Was actually not quite as simple as that but.
Really a combination of self interest. And confusion. And a tendency to paranoia.
Others you soon that is there's no water she was full of rotten because it's now locked in the pot and.
I think it's something deep in human nature to. When our fundamental resources are threatened or the land or water.
We immediately. Try to blame somebody rather than to look at what the real problem is it's instinctive and.
People tended to have a lot of always hear first talk of no mentality. Picu thwart.
The shift to a place where there was a reliable stream. And then be unwilling to share it.
Not realizing that water is really very much a public property. I mean even one stream astrologer it's public property.
Except at west we can bond so water rights. But that. You can't just sort of grab water. Toms and.
All right from the beginning. I saw a problem.
In that people were taken out of a war and called a fully serviced environment in the suburbs and.
Dropped in very beautiful surroundings but. Surroundings in which nearly all the fundamental surfaces were missing.
And suddenly the issues of. Well let's run through them. There's no sewage pipes. No water pipes. No roads.
No phone lines. No electricity. Like i think i've run through five. Fundamental services all missing.
And it was very difficult for people to accommodate to the. Enormous sudden drop in the standard of living.
And the bus psychologically unprepared and physically unprepared to take that step back in servicing level.
And i could run through each one of those fov services and the mess ups that happens the result of people's.
Attempts to get a wife to do without them. And that i think is the story.
Of this community as much as a political story as much as a social story.
The story of the effect of withdrawal of services from people.
One instinct like of just mentioned is that people fought for what he used. So you get power politics into a trip out.
Politics. By stay on the. The roads. The electricity which is here.
And the other side of this you get people suffering terrible.
Depreciation for not knowing how to get around the lack of those services.
In the first year we had a lot of the human life by being expended carrying. Containers of water up hills.
People didn't.
Realize that it was actually abundant water at high altitude he it's just a question of knowing how to pocket.
But that. Total lack of skill.
Of dealing with fundamental resources and how to supply them for yourself caused an awful lot of suffering.
You know saying those things are enormous. We had houses but down by people using candles.
We had first to tell you on the property i think was a baby but to death that was a second wasn't it.
Anyway the point is that we had deaths. We had great suffering caused by people not knowing how to do without services.
And this is all totally foreseeable and expectable. Selective electricity caused people to get burnt to death.
Lack of communication. Caused people to dos night but that's not telephones. Like of roads cause people to dog many.
Mel nutrition in a couple of examples and. This not death also i was related to lack of pride's.
Lack of sewage caused hepatitis at. Outbreak. I think one person died of that. Lack of.
I've gone through them all like a board it caused unbelievable problems again with health.
And with you tonight of a conflict. So it's coming. Oh well. I came from a very practical background.
Because my father was a farmer and my training was only in physics and science and otherwise been a mechanic
and things like that. So i thought i came here with a very good schools price. Given a few rude shocks.
Early on by the difficulty of making services work.
The first thing i did was run up a water pipe and found that water would not run downhill through a pipe.
That was a bit of a shock to my conception of how the world works. Once i learned why.
It was a bit of a learning curve. With nearly everything. Everything you have to do.
It took a little while to get through those early setbacks. But soon we learnt to run. Water down pops.
That all started working nicely and.
That's been the story really is the last twenty years gradually getting alternative services going on your life like.
Getting it right for me. You know. I actually got an interest in run by power. After the failure of my.
If it's to try and provide service into this intentional community. I great plans for that for doing. Soft. Impact.
Transport. Water electricity supplies for the community and. I would call. Most of that as a fad yeah.
Partly the fault for under mr underestimating the difficulties. Partly that are the fault of just not enough capital.
Partly the fault of people not having confidence that these things could work and. The real.